as I started to get more and more
interested in how Erie's work the the
first class research varietal
improvement agronomy engineering all of
this how this could be more relevant to
different countries particularly
countries that had I would say have been
bypassed by the Green Revolution that
hadn't really taken off to the same
degree for a number of reasons partly
because of their environment because
they were largely rain-fed areas but but
also because of conflict and that's what
got me interested in the Indochina
region
January 1986 I was invited by dr.
swaminathan to be part of a team that
went to to Cambodia then known as
Kampuchea and it was good if cush it was
Don Pak region myself and so we went
there for about 10 days in January 86 it
had been a request from the Ministry of
Agriculture it initially actually come
from some NGOs working in Cambodia they
wanted eariy they were asking eariy to
return some of the seeds that we had in
the gene bank they were interested in
getting the rice industry up and running
again after a long period of great
disruption actually to the rice farming
in the country so we went on in that in
that first mission and and lots of
interesting things came of that as a
result
i-it's a it's it's it's a remarkable
story and and one that you know I wish I
wish more people knew about that because
it is such a compelling example of how
genetic conservation is is so critical
particularly you know for countries like
Cambodia that are so reliant on
agriculture and in this case so reliant
on rice production so Cambodia you know
has one would call it a quite a
checkered history it leading up to the
end of the Vietnam War actually the
country was very productive
not necessarily high-yielding but they
were generating surpluses of rice from
Cambodia leading up to about you know 70
to 73 as the Vietnam War was sort of
coming to an end but it was spilling
over into into Cambodia and Laos and so
at one point are sort of in the late 60s
the the country had an area of around
two and a half million hectares of rice
and they were actually exporting small
amounts of that to other parts of the
world particularly to Africa actually
but as the war spilled over and there
was a very strong anti-government
movement going on in the rural areas
more and more people more and more
Cambodians actually fled the countryside
and made their way into pen on pen and
they sought refuge there actually so the
population of the city increased from
half a million to about two million
people and at the same time the area
planted to rice decreased and decreased
in decreased large areas were affected
by land mines as the conflict was going
on so Cambodia went from being a net
surplus country to being a country that
really couldn't feed itself because
everybody or at least a big proportion
of the population were huddled into the
cattles
so that sort of led us up to 1975 and I
think it was sometime in April 75 the
Khmer Rouge actually took over the
government
so the Lawndale government disappeared
and then we had a period of three and a
half almost four years of what's known
as The Killing Fields so the Khmer Rouge
came in with a very I would call it
unorthodox but also brutal approach to
development and their view was we needed
to bring the whole country back to Year
Zero and the way to do that in order to
rid the country of all the ills that
they saw had affected Cambodia over the
years they the first thing they did was
actually remove everybody from pen on
pen so here we are we have two million
people essentially plotted into the city
within a few weeks of the arrival of the
Khmer Rouge the population went down to
10,000 imagined from 2 Millions 10,000
and so where did they send they
basically redistributed them all over
the country and not necessarily back to
the places where they came from part of
the ideology of the Khmer Rouge and it
was a very interesting one as they they
recognized that Cambodia's rice was
important okay but they wanted to
modernize it and their idea of
modernization was to irrigate rice and
to be the sort of base somehow loosely
based the concept on the old anchor
civilization large grids of irrigation
canals and so that sort of you can now
sort of conjure up those images in the
killing fields of very large numbers of
essentially slave laborers out there
digging ditches and trying to create
irrigation canals the idea was somehow
and they were at that time they had
Chinese advisors the the Chinese
government had supported the Khmer Rouge
and the idea there were even introducing
rice varieties from China to plant in
these areas but with hindsight now
looking at all that the the the the
engineering was was extremely faulty
very little of that irrigation that
infrastructure ever led to any increase
in irrigated rice production and they
abandoned in fact the Khmer Rouge
actually outlawed deep water rice they
didn't allow farmers to plant this
traditional deep water rice they used to
plant around the Tonle Sap Lake and so
over that period production went right
down to less than less than a million
tons even half a million tonnes I've
seen some of the statistics during that
period which was way less than you
needed to feed a population
notwithstanding the fact that the Khmer
Rouge actually killed upwards of two
million people over that period you know
one of the greatest genocides in in in
human history
so this went on for you know for three
and a half four years finally in January
79 the Vietnamese came into Cambodia and
installed a new government they removed
the Khmer Rouge partly because the
government the Cambodian government the
Khmer Rouge government was launching
attacks on Vietnam and Vietnam of course
was a much more powerful force and at
that time also I think China had also
reduced and eventually not supported the
Khmer Rouge because Vietnam and had its
battles with China on the northern front
as well anyway so Vietnam comes back in
installs a new government led by Hun Sen
who is still the leader to this very day
that was 79 and slowly NGOs sort of
trickled into the country no UN because
for many years that government was
considered illegitimate because it had
been installed by a an occupation force
the Vietnamese had come in and removed
the Khmer Rouge so all along even the
time when eery ultimately started
working in Cambodia the the Khmer Rouge
actually occupied the seat in the UN and
so there was no UN presence in fact all
through this period that we worked in
the early days that we worked there
the only governments that recognized the
Hun Sen government at that time were the
with a Soviet the Soviet Union and the
Soviet bloc countries including Cuba and
one other country one that was not in
that sphere of influence and that was
India okay so you had all of the Soviet
bloc but no Western governments
recognized the government in Cambodia
including Australia did not as well so
anyway we actually several years passed
and then when we were invited in finally
dr. swaminathan received the invitation
we went into the country at that point
this is early 1986 production had crept
back up to about two million tons yields
were still very low but just land area
expansion as the
some of the problems had been sort of
solved in terms of security it wasn't
completely secure and they're still
landmines everywhere which seriously
affected agriculture and particularly
rice farming people as well as animals
were being blown up by stepping on
landmines but anyway there was a bit of
an increase in production
so the erie program came in and we we
looked around and and we were we were
shocked i would say in that first
mission we we couldn't quite believe
what we saw or we'd heard not a lot of
information came out to the outside
world during that Khmer Rouge period but
we started to talk to people we started
to talk to the government officials we
started to talk to everyday folks this
was a hard-line communist government by
the way that we were dealing with back
then anyway but they did realize we have
to feed our people right we have to
increase production they had that idea
so we said okay let's let's take a look
at who we can work with and you know
like we typically work with a national
research organization right they became
our partners you look around Cambodia
all the buildings were destroyed
everything had been destroyed we've got
some great photos from that era of what
were formerly research institutions in
the 70s totally flattened
where are the people there were 400
trained agriculturalists in the country
prior to the war after the war there
were 40 so you had a literal decimation
of the aggregate the skilled
agricultural expertise people who had
worked in extension or Ministry of
Agriculture and and and in the
university and so on
so there were very few people available
to work with in fact one of the things
we did before we went to Cambodia was
Erie used to have this book I don't know
if you still have this now where you
could they have little photographs of
all the Erie trainees going back for
years right and so we looked at Cambodia
to see who'd done a training course at
Erie actually they'd only been six who
there were six faces and six names there
but we brought this with us and we
started asking around everybody we saw
you know of course the first thing we
tried to do is so who has a connection
to Erie here that we could start to work
with and we could only we didn't
actually physically locate them but we
only heard of two of those six still
still alive right so they've really been
wiped out the human resources the
physical infrastructure wiped out and
the varieties were lost as well because
with all that dislocation with the fact
that everybody moved from the
countryside and then they went through
this horrendous period of you know work
slave camps basically and also being
told you can't plant this they bought a
rice and and people were so hungry they
ate their rice seeds right so you
basically lost so much of the genetic
resources the the rice genetic resources
which were essential in Cambodia because
85% of the fields were were rain fed and
so Erie's impact up into that point had
been very much focused in the irrigated
and rain fed and favorable rain fed
lowlands had very little impact on the
on the sort of more harsher environments
so all these traditional varieties in
Cambodia had evolved under these harsh
conditions but appeared to have been
lost
however we have a good news story and
the good news story was that luckily
while probably more than luck very
strategically Erie had sent in some
collectors I don't personally know the
names who actually did this but I
believe it was 72 and 73 just towards
the period where the production and the
you know the turmoil began there had
been a collection of rice varieties
traditional rice varieties and I believe
over 750 varieties probably more than
that were actually collected and stored
in the e regime back so we did our
checks on we called up the folks in the
gene bank and we found out that yes
indeed we've got all these varieties
that were collected at that point about
13 or 14 years previously they'd live
safely in the gene bank while this
horrendous you know genocide civil war
was going on in Cambodia so over a
period of several years part of the URI
program in Cambodia was actually to
reintroduce those varieties and we had
one plant we had a couple of plant
breeders there Ram Chaudhary edwin
javier and they worked on reintroduction
of these traditional varieties and many
of those varieties then farmers you know
grabbed them went with them multiplied
them so we had a sort of a two pronged
process or a two pronged approach one
was to get these traditional ones back
into places where they best fitted the
other part was where we've got irrigated
rice and we still had 15% of the country
maybe a little more irrigated let's get
state-of-the-art modern IR varieties in
their IR 36 and so on like that had gone
very well in other parts of Asia had
still not found their way at least not
good quality seeds of those varieties
had found their way into Cambodia so had
these two things going at once so we
then saw a big yeah well it wasn't big
to start with it was slight let's say a
slow improvement in production that has
continued you know to this very day
so so the varietal improvement part of
it was was very important I can't
underestimate the importance of the
human resources and as I mentioned the
human resources had been decimated as a
result of the war people that either
been killed or they'd fled as refugees
and and disappeared off the map as far
as Cambodia was concerned so a major
initial focus of our work was on
capacity building so this wasn't easy
because virtually nobody they spoke
English
so one of the first things we did was
actually bring a group of Cambodians to
Erie and I believe it was sometime in 87
that we brought this group of 13
Cambodians from Cambodia to Erie this
was the largest group of Cambodians ever
to leave the country
remember nobody actually well it's a
ever to leave the country other than to
the Soviet Union or other sort of parts
of the world that were friendly with
Cambodia at that time so we brought the
13 of we organized to bring them to to
Erie and we brought them for five months
of training we we had a special rice
production training course everything
had to be translated into Khmer and what
they did was in the mornings they did
rice production and in the afternoons
they did English training so we had the
the training center of Erie I'll have
them out in the field planting rice
doing all the physical stuff while it
wasn't raining and in the afternoon they
came in and we had a woman Jill Sullivan
we we brought her in and she taught
English sort of English for beginners
and so this went on for five months and
these people went back to Cambodia and
we ended up being able to work with them
so parallel with sort of improvements
and technical assistance and all the
rest was building up this capacity and
over you know a period of about 12 15
years or so about 6,000 Cambodians were
trained by Erie at all levels many of
them of course were trained in country
and at one point we had a team
about five or six eerie scientists
working there but many of them we you
know we brought them back to Erie we
sent them to other we sent them on tours
they got to see other parts of the world
where we'd actually made good progress
in rice production and some of them then
went on to get master's degrees and even
PhDs
so we look at Cambodia today we helped
set up the cambodian Agricultural
Research & Development Institute called
car D we did that very early in the
piece and then we worked very closely to
build up national capacity from scratch
physical infrastructure as well as the
human resources to go with it and we
with support from the Australian
government we were able to send quite a
large number of students off for
Advanced Education to do masters and
PhDs mostly in Australia some of them
did it here in the Philippines as well
and to this day if you go and look at
the organizational chart of of car D and
you look at it over the last several
years the people who were running the
organization the the current director
for example Makara has his PhD in
Australia is one of our counterparts one
of the trainees and many others in the
organization leading breeding and soils
and entomology and so on all came
through this eerie partnership that was
supported mainly by Australia over those
period of a you know a couple of decades
so that's the that's sort of the history
in terms of what we did it I took a lot
about varieties but we worked on
agronomy we worked on integrated pest
management post-harvest technology
mechanization all of these things were
going on at the same time over a you
know rather a long period and you know I
I look at it when when we went in in
January 86
the production in the country was around
2 million tons the average yield was
just over 1 ton per hectare and I look
at it today what is it almost 30 years
later right total production in the
country is is around 9 million
all right the country is an exporter
again in fact for the last several years
the country has been exporting somewhere
around 800,000 to a little over a
million tons per year they've really
developed their export export of Rice's
as a source of income the you know the
area has gone back to above the level it
was even before the war from about two
and a half million hectares having gone
down to half a million now back up to
three million hectares so it hasn't
greatly expanded much of the improvement
has come through yield increases so the
yield is now around three million three
three tons per hectare which is you know
it doesn't it's not that good perhaps
compared to Vietnam or Indonesia but
you've got to remember that still that
country is largely rain fed irrigation
has expanded investments have expanded
but to be able to get three tonnes per
hectare of land that is principally
rain-fed means that you know a lot has
gone into the improvement of crop
production so I think it's a great you
know Cambodia itself is a great credit
to Yuri and I think initially the vision
of director-general dr. Swaminathan and
consistent long-term partnership with
with that country through thick and thin
challenges of funding for the most part
Australia was the was the big supporter
but we were able over the years to
diversify that level of support and one
of the key successes is we've been able
to connect Cambodian scientists with
scientists in other countries we always
wanted that we didn't we didn't want
them to be dependent only on area with
the Lao with the Vietnamese with the
Indonesians with the Chinese again and
build those sort of collegial
relationships which would give you know
give strength to the to the national
research system so that's that's
basically the Cambodia story I think
that that is actually a really good
lesson which by the way I've shared with
a number of other you know colleagues in
other parts of the world as far away as
Africa
you know that when we see countries
coming out of conflict we we you know I
think we can take some lessons from from
what happened in Cambodia I've tried to
have sort of similar approaches being
used in in in East Timor into molestor
again a country coming out of conflict
it's not it's not a predominantly rice
growing area but but I think the general
principle when you come out of conflict
you've you've often got minimal
infrastructure
you've got very limited human resources
and you you often need to borrow
technology and build up research
capacity yourself so we've looked at
that in timor-leste we looked at that in
Mozambique I know here he's now working
in Mozambique I think doing a very
similar approach improving varieties
building national capacity and
strengthening national institutions it's
a good model and I think it it should be
shared more widely and it's probably
going to be very relevant to Afghanistan
and and perhaps some other parts of the
world in the years ahead
not just for rice but for any crop
nation
you